there was violence as some protesters
fought with police in Paris during what
had otherwise been a peaceful
demonstration thousands of people had
turned out to express their anger about
inflation climate change and the French
government's planned pension reforms
[Music]
we're together against inflation pension
reforms and public services reforms it's
important people are battling everywhere
even in the oil refineries
I think a lot of people understand that
the climate's being destroyed it's
obvious but it's about convincing those
in power
Nobel literature prize winner Annie erno
took part in the demonstration alongside
its organizer opposition leader Jean-Luc
malosa
[Applause]
is addressing the crowd on that float
behind me he called for this protest and
he will hope that it will help
Revitalize the left-wing Alliance that
in recent months has been plagued by
rivalry
[Applause]
with what we are achieving here today
with workers and political organizations
we are creating a new popular front that
will one day take power in this country
when the time comes
the political left has been somewhat
eclipsed in recent weeks by France's
trade unions which have led a number of
strikes including the recent oil
refinery walkouts at a time when
pressure on the government is mounting
monosha wants to regain the spotlight
and ensure his left-wing Alliance
remains a significant opposition Force
Natasha Butler Al Jazeera Paris